في ظل هذه الظروف ناشده منسق الامم
المتحده الاقليميه للشؤون الانسانيه
للازمه السوريه مهند هادي نشد الدول
المانحه لتقديم المساعدات المنكوبين من
الزلازل في سوريا واضاف هذه في مقابله على
الجزيره ان الشعب السوريه عانه من ويلات
الحرب على مدى سنوات طويله وجاء الزلزال
ليفاقم معاناته وهو بحاجه لاي مساعده
ممكنه
بوجه رساله الى الجميع ليس فقط لكل
للمشاهدين على الجزيره لما تنظروا للاطفال
وللنساء ولا كبار السن اللي بيعانوا
تخيلوا لا سمح الله انه هدول ناس اقربائكم
تخيلوا ان هدول الناس فقط اشخاص انتم ما
بتعرفوهم يعني حسوا بدنا جميع يحس مع
الناس سواء دول او حكومات او شعوب الشعب
السوري بحاجه الى الى مساعده الشعب السوري
مر فيها ويلات الحرب لاكثر من عشر سنين
والان الزلزال فوق كل هذه المعاناه فعلا
يعني هذا فوق ما يتحمله اي اي انسان
ونناشد الجميع بمساعده الشعب السوري
وتقديم المساعدات الى الشعب السوري
كما عرب المنسق الامامي للشؤون الانسانيه
في سوريا مهند هادي في مقابله على الجزيره
اربعا امله في ان تتمكن اولى شاحنات
المساعدات من العبور يوم غدا الخميس الى
داخل الاراضي السوريه من خلال معبر باب
الهوى
في معوقات لوجستيه كثيره الطرق جزء منها
كبير قد قد تضرر
واصبحت غير يعني اصبحت امكانيه وصول
الشاحنات صعبه لكن المعلومات اللي وصلتنا
بعد ظهر اليوم انه اصبحت الطريق الان
سالكه الى حد ما طبعا مشتركه بالطريقه
اللي كانت قبل قبل الزلزال لكن ممكن انها
الشاحنات تصل الى الحدود وطبعا في
الشاحنات اللي بدها تيجي من المناطق
السوريه ليتم تبديل المواد من من الشاحنات
التركيه الى الشاحنات السوريه نامل وكلنا
امل انه بكره نستطيع انه
نتمم موضوع النقل المساعدات عبر الحدود